[Applause]
66-52 16 for James and a timeout called
by Memphis and some Wars exchange with
Brooks
walking the other way LeBron James had
something to say well he said take all
two of these right here for talking a
lot they said I'm gonna give you some
more and it's gonna be fun to watch
[Music]
the top of Dylan Brooks and as they went
down the floor they switched between
nothings into each other's ears yeah
you know I thought the first game would
be a little more chippy than it actually
was so this is kind of what I Brooks
initially on this hit or you'll see it
in a moment after the stare down by
Brooks and LeBron just wouldn't return
the favor yeah but I think on that one
Reeves had a little acting on that he
got hit he was acting a little bit more
watch this watch
maybe not from my angle I look like it
but he took that hit the officials
didn't call it so got away with one